I was about to say good morning.
Good evening, folks. Uh
yeah,
there's more work to do a little bit.
I figured
I figured the porting for this can be
done
almost
automatically, so I may as well.
Let me go check real quick here. I'll
flip the screen over.
Let me just go check real quick whether
I have credits for this or whether this
is going to be the switch to codeex
time.
All right, here's what we're going to do
for
All right,
that's probably good enough.
It's a very simple set of changes to be
fair. I got no energy left to do them
though. But I think I can at least make
sure this doesn't break it.
The plan is going to be we update
Puffernet,
we do a few of the ends
with the tune parameters
and then Tomorrow
we finish all the M's, we finish all the
experiments, we call it a day.
We'll get one more set of experiments
overnight, which will be nice.
Oh, I think actually 2048's running now.
I should make sure that is stable.
It's actually really important.
Not great perf actually on this.
A little bit odd.
Oh yeah, that's not going to be hard.
Yeah, it'll be very easy.
The weight should get saved FP32 anyways
though, so it should be fine.
Two different people making our SM. It's
pretty awesome.
actually a lot of the stuff in here is
going to be quite simple.
There's some stuff I can do in the
meantime.
This is done.
Read me.
Hang on. We can update this a little bit
as well.
Aphen is there's a difference linear and
a right
going to actually review this stuff
carefully. These are good fixes.
We'll update the default net.
Oh, I see. The default's different.
I do hope we're going to be able to um
to run the
new models.
The new puffer model's kind of chunky.
Hello. Welcome.
Long grind day.
The hope is today, tomorrow, and we're
done. That's the hope.
Oh, cuz it's numbum layers. That's
actually a fine use.
Uh, is that a fine use?
I think it's float star, isn't it?
No, this is correct. It is It is um
float star. Wait. Yeah.
state
output buffer.
Wait,
It is kind of cool to have it be that
like this, but I think it's it's better
to have um
have it a little bit separated.
Oh yeah, it is linear. It actually
caught that.
It's not apping. It's linear.
through analysis two
if that's functional analysis that's
already more math than I know
so you're not bottlenecked by math
you're bottlenecked by engineering Okay.
one?
Oh, it is three deep.
testing out puffer 4 for tower defense.
Nice.
I will be reviewing a bunch of NPRs
next week. I'm going to be flopped. Like
I'm just gonna be not doing anything
other than making sure Puffer is not on
fire. The week after is probably going
to be when I start.
Maybe I'm being obsessive about the
math.
Let me show you the math that actually
ended up being puffer 4
here.
You'll see how simple it is if you're
thinking of stuff like that.
ready for what actually ended up working
for Puffer 4. How we got soda on
everything?
Oh, here it's in my This is the draft.
Here you go.
That's it.
The uh Adam had product operator there
is elementwise.
This is sigmoid.
That's literally it.
And because that's too hard for most um
ML people here it is in pretty picture
form.
Like the thing that makes this tick is a
parallel prefix scan,
but it's not like it's really not
abstract math.
There are a few places in AI where you
can do some more math heavy things to be
fair, but I think that most people that
I meet are bottlenecked more by than
math.
Like I'm not an idiot, right? If math if
the math were super useful, I would have
spent more time on it. I spent my time
getting good at engineering.
real analysis helped outside of ML.
If you like math, then by all means,
right? I personally I have not enjoyed
math as much.
I really have not enjoyed math anywhere
as much. I like building things.
I like thinking about problems, but I
like thinking about problems in a very
different way.
Mathematics feels at least like
proofbased mathematics feels a lot more
like solving puzzles to me.
I don't enjoy math.
Well, then don't force yourself to do
it. Do some
not knowing it is a bottleneck. Thege
bottlenecks is super hard. Not knowing
though.
does it work?
It should not drop any balls.
Well, I mean, actually, it might, but it
should not lose.
This is the new model deployed in pure
C.
I mean, it's not that complicated. It's
kind of funny where the new model it's
actually simpler I think than the LSTM
slightly. H maybe about the same. It's
like 20 lines of code though and see
like the uh the new gates.
Some dinguses have been trying to tell
me that the layer is actually better
because it's fast.
But when I tried the layer norm [ __ ] it
was super slow.
I'm liking my highway nets for now.
We don't really have to worry about
fusing it with the mat mole
cuz like we fuse it with the rest of the
stuff anyways. Okay, it lost one ball,
but it lost one ball on the last brick
of the first screen.
I mean, the low-level dev that I've been
doing, the proof of it, right, is in the
last couple of years with all the the
low-level dev I've been picking up, I've
made RL as a field a,000x faster
and I've been able to actually make core
algorithmic breakthroughs because of
I mean like look at this this policy
you're watching here. This policy was
trained in 4 seconds.
So it took 4 seconds to get a basically
perfect breakout model.
sometimes drops a couple balls on um the
last couple tiles, but boom, that's a
full solve.
Can run it on a toaster.
Yeah, breakout used to take more than a
day to solve for reference.
That's the new puffer architecture.
It kind of rocks.
Muffin. I looked into it. I can't go to
Streamlabs or anything else. So, unless
there's something from OBS that can set
all the titles every time, there's not
really a way for me to do it.
What's the most complex environment?
It's one of the most complex
environments in the field. Neural MMO 3.
This is a massively multi-agent
environment. You have a thousand agents
running around in here along with a
whole bunch of uh enemy NPCs.
There is It's like all the classic MMO
stuff. You can level up. You can train
two different skills. You can gather
resources. Uh there are different tiers
of armor and weapons and equipment. Um
there's a global market. You can buy and
sell things with other agents.
this thing. I trained this model on
12,000 years worth of games
play.
And the new model that we just trained
for Puffer 4 that I'm going to be trying
to integrate tonight, we trained for,
I believe, closer to 18,000 years.
the wrongs. It's uses the mana seed
assets.
A lot of things use those
How long did 18k years take to train?
Three and a half days on 6490s.
But we have a really really bad
convolution implementation.
And I believe we could make it two to
three times faster. We can probably get
it down to about one day for that amount
of data. And that amount of data is over
a pabyte of compressed observations.
Probably like seven or eight pabytes
uncompressed.
Why does the load weights take the size
of the weights and explicit arg?
How would you compute the number of
weights?
and it's not the number of weights it's
the number of bytes of the file isn't
it?
Maybe you're right.
It's awkward cuz there's padding and
[ __ ]
Yeah. See, this is not a perfect model.
Something is slightly off.
I probably can and I will do that. Let
me figure out why this model's not
perfect.
I've done that before, Muffin. It
doesn't stick.
It only sticks if you stream through the
Twitch thing instead of OBS.
I mean, I probably should just not be
lazy and set it or whatever.
I can't really think about that now,
though. Muffin. I got zero zero brain
cells left. I mean, zero.
I got a pretty decent bench though
because all I've been doing other than
that is benching all week.
Everyday bench day.
I should go move the bench press like
obnoxiously close to the camera like
right behind me.
New PR rep PR. Yeah. Uh 225 for 8 and
245 for five.
I'm not really doing 1RMP PRS right now
cuz um I'm kind of bench and not warmed
up. So
I've kind of just been taking the like
pyramid
um like you know the like light medium
heavy back to light but slightly heavier
light medium heavy light med like that
that you do week by week and compressing
it into three Yes.
It's probably frame skip, right?
Let's watch this for a bit. I bet it's
frame skip.
What do you think about doing a PhD in
RL for robotics?
I only ever suggest that people do a PhD
who already want to do a PhD and they're
sure of it. I never try to convince
anybody to do a PhD.
Yeah. So this is perfect
I could check this manually,
but like
brain cells, you know,
I got a limited number of those.
Um, honestly, there's very little that
comes out.
When there's something that I actually
need to see, it almost always gets sent
to me by one of my colleagues or
somebody in the puffer community or I
see it on Twitter or I get messaged it
by a friend. Um there's like very very
little other than that.
Like the uh the two major things that
ended up mattering for Puffer 4 were two
much older papers
that I kind like one of which I knew
from research I'd done before and one of
which was like mentioned to me in
passing in conversation.
you probably have this impression that
there's like tons of new Well, maybe in
robotics it's different, but in RL as a
whole, if you have this impression that
there's tons of new stuff coming out
constantly, there really isn't.
Like, RL would still be running at um
1,000 steps per second without Puffer
Lib.
Like, this is the only reason it's fast.
And now Puffer Lib's kind of gotten far
enough ahead that like we are the new
stuff to keep up with.
At least for the more practical side of
things, right? If you're into theory,
that's a different story.
It like looked like it was phasing
through there.
Wait, but it's too Isn't it too
Is it one?
This is fine.
Wait, logic size is three, but that's
fine.
How do I avoid lying? This is like the
worst possible time to be watching me
for that. You're catching me on the
second to last stream
before uh after.
So, I checked. I've apparently streamed
900 hours of dev for this release.
So, I have no remaining brain cells um
to be doing anything at the moment,
but I'm really not a huge fan of the AI
tools.
So, you'll see me doing a lot more stuff
myself when I have the brain cells for
it. And at the moment, I'm making sure
it's not making a mess of crap. And I'm
mostly using it to like port [ __ ] and
find [ __ ]
900 games during the day here. Yeah,
this 900 hours of streaming in eight
months,
but then presumably I've done, you know,
at least another 300 hours of work.
Probably more than that, right?
Yeah, because I dev sometimes off stream
and I do client work off stream
industry and tech from here. No,
absolutely not.
How do you read researchers and get the
most of it?
Well, first I check the thing and I get
I get my own probabilistic estimate that
thing is [ __ ] And if that's high,
then I don't read the paper.
If it's decently low, then I look for
skeletons in the closet in the normal
places.
And when I find those 90% of the time,
then I go, "Well, this is bullshit." And
I stop rating it. And if I don't find
any of those, then I sit down and
actually see what they're doing. And
then maybe try to like try it out and
see if it makes sense for stuff.
Token maps rabbit hole. It's weird.
It's laziness.
I mean, you've seen me do a lot of like
a lot of LM changes in the last couple
weeks before release, especially.
At the very least, though, it's pretty
constrained in the changes I'm making to
stuff. It's a lot of port this code I
wrote over to here or refactor this in
this very specific way.
I'm not you're not going to see me
saying like, "Oh, go write a neural net
library.
I honestly have no idea what's wrong
with this, though.
I wonder does the frame skip parameter
match? Is it off by one?
Wait, frame skip.
It depends how it's implemented, doesn't
it?
Okay. So, frame skip of one for this
end.
So, no, this is correct then,
right? Puffer five.
The thing is that there are like there
are people who are supposed to be smart
on Twitter who are genuinely dumb enough
to think that you can do that
like oh but with verifiability it can
always bootstrap from its mistakes and
it'll just infinitely produce things
and it's just like hey whoever's up
there can you just shoot one of us
Please.
It's like either me so I don't have to
listen to it or him so I don't have to
listen to it.
I just want everybody to [ __ ] off so we
can do real science. Sick of the grift,
you know.
They can go do that at all they want.
Just like stay away from me. Leave me
alone. Leave me to do the real work.
Don't even get me started on the AI
writing TypeScript
like
You get to join an elite club of people
who give a [ __ ] simply by giving a [ __ ]
there.
You kind of got to understand the system
to make big breakthroughs. Okay, this
thing here
especially
this thing here
especially this thing here right here. Understand how science is
right here. Understand how science is
done. You really really really have to
understand how [ __ ] everything is.
like, "Oh, what am I going to do? Wait,
how am I going to do anything important?
I'm one person who barely knows
anything, and they're all these
brilliant people at all these companies
raising all this money." Lies. All
right, there's like five dudes at each
company that do any real work, and the
rest of them [ __ ] around, look pretty,
and actually break all the code.
Same in science. Vast majority of the
papers fake. They don't actually work.
They work on the one stupid benchmark
and they don't work anywhere else. Half
the time you can't even get them to work
on the one stupid benchmark they say
they work on.
You can just ignore 90% of the stuff out
there. Think about it. Right? If
everything you saw on Twitter, all the
cool things were real, we'd be in sci-fi
utopia now. Why aren't we? Cuz they're
almost all fake.
And I don't mean that like conspiracy
like tinfoil hat. I mean they're like
vastly overselling to the point that you
may as well just ignore them.
That's how you actually get started
is you recognize it's not that hard
because the bar is a lot lower than you
think.
Now all you got to do is you got to be
good enough that you stand out more than
the people who spend all their time
faking it instead of actually being
good. That's all you got to do.
Huh?
Well, this is how you measure it. They
all go back and forth on each other on
their stupid benchmarks every other
month. They're all building the exact
same thing. They're all wildly
overselling their stuff to raise tons of
money and to get you to use their
product.
It literally ported the thing to Python
to test.
That's hilarious.
What? You're just getting like you're
just going through like the scam of the
day. They have [ __ ] all.
Um, it's more the way that they're
trained more than the model
architecture.
I think you need a lot more RL
and the models are like I guess the labs
just plan to spend all the money in the
world, but like it's
there's something deeply wrong because
you really don't need that big of models
or that much compute to make some crazy
domain specific like task specific RL
models and they're kind of just making
the giant slot machine and then trying
to RL it very very weakly at the end.
I think the approach is kind of [ __ ]
Well, that was a pain in the ass to
find.
Okay,
that's why Pong is crap.
Bug fix Pong.
Um, I think kind of all the
implementations are pretty stupid bet
because there's not a great way to do
it.
There's some that are stupider than
others though.
Well, yeah, there are many ways to
implement that though. Bet.
All right, this is basically a perfect
model, right?
Puffers like stars.
Guys, how many different M do I have to
make about puffers eating stars before
y'all will just star the puffer on
GitHub? I mean, look, it's literally
puffers eating stars
trained with RL
in 10 seconds.
I think you can use AI if you're in
freaking chemo, dude,
The real question about is have you been
staying in shape rather than just
[ __ ] around with the GPT?
I've done a pretty [ __ ] job staying in
shape on the running with um
with this crazy ass release, though I've
been running a few easy 5ks in the last
few days. The bench is good, though.
Shape can still do push-ups.
Well, I can rep two plates, so
there's uh something.
Not great.
You have to personally interview them.
And there's no such thing as good with
AI.
It literally takes absolutely no, it
doesn't take any learning whatsoever.
It's just pure dev skills.
If you're a good dev, you're good with
AI.
It's like, "Oh, well, he's really good
in C, but I don't know if he's going to
be good in Python."
Like, my dude,
you can give me any language and I'll
[ __ ] about the language being stupid,
but yeah, I can write code in it.
You don't think B,
huh? This Claude Code app [ __ ] sucks,
dude. The only thing impressive than
Enthropic has is the models and the RL
on the models. The [ __ ] Claude Code
app and whatever dumb for loops it runs
over them is nothing.
It's probably a complete embarrassment.
In fact, apparently it's 500,000 lines
of code.
I don't have any beef with um I don't
have any beef with like the well okay
there are a few stupid things with the
design of it but one is like people
confusing the actual real difficult and
interesting part of AI of building the
models doing the RL that stuff with like
writing for loops over models
and they like the agentic AI horeshit,
which is not a thing. It's just writing
for loops over models. It's not done
particularly well either.
Um, and then I also just don't like
Enthropic as a company. They're insane.
So, I'm not going to give them more
praise than they deserve for sure.
Like with Open AI at least, I
specifically don't like Ultman. Like
there are a lot of awesome people at
OpenAI that rock. with Enthropic. I
don't I don't like Enthropic the whole
damn company.
Okay. But they're literally writing four
loops over the model.
Like in that case, it's basically
symbolic systems at that. Like I can
make an agentic AI in that case
by scripting a uh scripting a policy for
breakout.
It's really stupid.
That level of dumb agent was the norm.
Yeah, but the thing is agent isn't has
always been the RL word, right?
Agent has been the word you use for RL
in 2013.
Like they've co-opted it to describe
their shitty for loops.
The agents are trained through
interaction.
You don't just take a model that you
don't just take a model, write four
loops over it, and say, "Oh, it's a
gentic." Now,
now they blur the lines a little bit
because they're doing a bunch of
pre-training and then some RL,
even though it's really shitty RL,
but the majority of it is these stupid
for loops.
It can act, but the thing is that
doesn't matter because anything can act,
right?
You can take a supervised model, deploy
it in a for loop, and call it a gentic,
but that's meaningless.
When we say when we say agents in RL,
we're referring to models that were
trained through interaction.
It's as much the training process as it
is the evaluation. They're one and the
same.
Yeah, but Starship, they're kind of
dated.
Like, I'm taking the stuff from this the
dawn of modern AI, from the dawn of deep
learning. Those made sense.
I guess the axiom here or the more the
conjecture that RL relies upon here is
that interaction is fundamental to
intelligence
and thus it's part of the training
procedure.
Carmarmac is doing mostly reasonable
things, but they're overly focused on
sample efficiency.
If Carmarmac just did what I was doing,
he'd win. But he doesn't. I mean, win is
a stupid word.
He's not a competitor. The only
competitors I have are um
what?
Death, ignorance, and the madness of
men. Let's try that. Those are real.
Those are good competitors.
We're struggling to compete with all of
these guys.
I'll just show them the hours streamed
and say, "Yeah, you guys can try that if
you want.
Good luck.
I like delete lots of code
because guess what? Puffer is so smart.
We no longer need a custom network.
That's right. The default network works
for mobile.
Isn't that pretty?
Look at that.
That's a happy puffer.
run it down mid puffer.
That's right.
Did you just set it up? Actually, if you
play around with it, let me know if
anything's wrong. And this is like
launch in two days.
How we doing on 2048?
Oh, I checked this before, right? It's
still going.
buffer record score.
I actually don't know on the latest
version, bet. We're sweeping it at the
moment.
What are you up to? Al, how is the brain
not dead yet? It is, Jess.
I think I'm basically done for the
evening. Um,
How do you do constellation vssh? Just
ssh-x just
you have to have the docker set up
though. It's in the it'll be in the new
docs.
Uh, you want me to look? I can look at
it real quick.
Okay, I'm going to have to A few things
have changed since then, but nothing too
major.
Yeah, this has the info I need for sure.
I guess the other thing that you can
help with Spencer if you have time um
though I guess you'd need one box for
this like one single GPU box would be
just go through like open them all up in
constellation get the best hypers make
sure the runs repro and then get the uh
the checkpoints so that we can like
export we can take the checkpoints and
we can use them for the locals.
I think that's the only other thing we
got to do. Configs innies
Yeah, this is pretty much what I expect.
This is good.
Yeah, this is all the stuff I need. I
will have to do the merge, I think, in
the morning. Unless you really need this
right now, then I guess I can do this.
Um,
yeah, that's definitely what we want,
though.
Here, let's see. I'll show you the one
trail model real quick.
I have not seen this. Oh, I don't
actually know if this will work.
I guess we'll see.
It's actually a bit better than the
score says. Probably this is one of the
M's where horizon matters and like LSTM
state sets.
Yeah, that's level 15.
Holy. Yeah, that's god model.
It doesn't solve the env or anything,
but I know what to do to solve it now.
Uh, let me go get the tiny logs. Hang
on. Hang on.
You shouldn't lose them, but let me
look.
Definitely try not to lose them.
Uh, I remember the metric on trash
pickup being very weird,
That weird. No, it's fine. I think it's
fine.
But this right here for me,
this makes it all worth it.
Like, this is the coolest RL model I've
ever trained.
This is significantly better. This model
is significantly better than um the
training curve suggests. And I think
it's because of the uh the state
continuation.
It's like I think it's at least like a
good 30% better than the average score
suggests. Maybe higher.
Yeah, bet. But I have to reweep it. I'm
going to have to re-we it basically.
kill the music here. I'm dead tired.
I think the best thing for me to do at
the moment is to shut off the computer,
go do some stretching, listen to my
audio book,
and go to sleep.
Now, it's too late to chill. I'm not
going to play anything.
Not going to scroll Twitter.
I want to be done tomorrow.
If we're done tomorrow, that gives me a
float day where if I think of anything
weird that I've missed, I can set it.
But I can also just like ready for the
release.
Good.
Not stressed. Doing everything the
[ __ ] day before.
It gives you guys a day to test as well.
So users on Sunday,
Sunday, if you want to help test,
that'll be the day.
If you want to just play with Puffer 4 a
day ahead of launch and find anything,
that'll be the day. Stream all day
tomorrow, Jess.
Well, not before breakfast because I'm
still going to run tomorrow. I think I
normally don't run Saturdays, but I
think it'll help me to run.
I'm traveling on Monday as well. I'm out
Monday and Tuesday. I'll take my laptop
obviously.
Um
it's shitty timing with the release, but
is what it is.
I said Q1.
We're only a few days late.
I mean, originally I said the beginning
of the year, but we did more. So, I
think for this scope, we're good.
Yeah. Thank you all very much. If you
haven't started the repo, just star the
repo. It really does help. Um,
so the cool thing about this though is
it's two days and then whatever time I
take off and then as soon as I'm back,
we have some awesome awesome stuff to
do.
Like it's all the easy wins that I've
saved up on the research side. Like we
have so many different things to try. We
could very easily end up doubling the
performance of Puffer, like doubling the
uh the learning power in like a week. I
wouldn't be surprised at all.
And that's before we even get into the
heavy stuff that's planned that I know
will double the performance.
And I'm going to stream all of that.
It'll be cool.
time frame for five. The goal for five
is that we actually do it this year and
we don't delay again.
I'd like it to take less than this year
as well. I'd like it to be less than 9
months. I think I'd like it to be like a
no four or five month update would be
way happier.